at the start of last year someone paid
200 000
for a video highlight of a lebron james
dump
the sale sparked a wave of headlines
about digital collectibles and the nfts
that make them possible
this year nfts for sports media are
expected to generate over 2 billion in
transactions about double last year's
total and some of the sport world's
biggest teams leagues and stars are
getting in on the action
[Music]
so will early adopters see their digital
collections balloon in value just like
more traditional memorabilia
or are nfts in asset bubble just waiting
to burst
to answer these questions it's important
to understand where digital collectibles
are like their physical forerunners
and where they're not
here's what you need to know
[Music]
first up i wanted to talk to the man
behind nba top shot the platform where
the lebron dunk was bought and sold
so in the beginning of 2021 february
march we were seeing sales of top shot
moments well over 200 million dollars
per month
we're speaking now in the latter half of
2021 and that revenue is closer to 20
million per month what accounts for that
dramatic
gap the key thing is this season we
haven't actually dropped any of the rare
and legendary content yet so you have
moments that are um relatively common
things that are um up to 60 000 or more
and then you have these ultra ultra rare
moments so legendary moments they're
about 0.1
of the total quantity
of nfts on the platform and these are
some of these moments are out of 32
they're out of 49 and so they're rarely
available
on the marketplace
the lebron nft was one out of a
collection of 49 each with its own
serial number to represent when it was
minted on the blockchain
just like with limited edition trading
cards the fewer nfts there are the same
moment the more valuable they are on the
resale market
but there's more to it than that
should people think of moments as
digital trading cards i would say
they're more than just trading cards
because they're digital and because
they're nfts they can actually be used
in other experiences so we think of
these products as a new class of
products that give their customers
different benefits and powers that they
never really had before
to learn more about the kind of added
benefits sports collectors might expect
from their nfts i spoke to rich kleiman
what's up my name is rich kleiman
co-founder of 35 ventures
oh you want more yes
rich is a long-time manager of and
business partner with nba superstar
kevin durant together they've teamed up
with dapper labs to produce a range of
nft enabled content
for them
it's about giving fans more direct
access to kd than ever before
ultimately nfts will you know become a
complimentary piece and another form of
an athlete speaking directly to their
fans whether it's something built around
the nft or if it's a signature shoe
business that's complemented by an nft
that now we have another element to be
added to the way an athlete
promotes and markets something to a way
they monetize their ip to the way they
generate revenue for any of their other
businesses or just complementary to
something that may be happening in their
life period
these deals are happening across the
sports world
rob gronkowski the first professional
athlete to launch his own range of nfts
made over a million dollars auctioning
digital trading cards online
the buyer of the rarest card was also
given the chance to meet gronk in person
come to one of his games and even claim
vip access at one of his other
franchises
i am letting my fans be able to get a
piece of the action
and it's not just the players who are
alive to this
opportunity you see more and more
innovative owners taking a shot at ways
to incorporate it into their arena into
their
organization in general and more and
more leagues are engaging the way the
nba did with top shot and you see that
is a whole world of revenue that could
be generated in a whole world of
extending the brand that can be
generated and i think that's the crazy
amazing part of it is that it's
constantly being unlocked
one of the latest leaks to engage with
nfts is the nfl which kind of surprised
me actually
as the biggest and wealthiest league in
the united states the national football
league really doesn't need to rush into
an unproven market for the sake of new
revenue
so
what are they in it for
we're coming at it from the perspective
how can i best engage my fans and
we really do believe that younger
demographics will engage with digital
objects digital activities almost on a
primary basis
this might mean that the latest
generation of fans interact with the
sport through collectibles video games
and social media first and real life
game experiences second
but nfts could act as a gateway from one
to the other
today
someone may spend hours and hours of
time in a given year to craft their
franchise craft their team in madden
blockchain will enable
a
player of a video game to spend time
earn against that
and then take all of those earnings and
bring that to another game to a social
experience to
show those as a trophy somewhere
the idea of digital earnings that can be
taken from one platform to another could
help to unlock the metaverse a fully
immersive digital realm where fans can
build their own avatar
buy and sell merchandise and even attend
games all online
no one knows what the metaverse is going
to be but we all know it's going to be
something and it's going to be something
that's transformative and in the early
days those will probably look like
things that are how do i outfit my
avatar or my digital self to show my
fandom in the future you could very
easily see this become what's my game
day experience in the metaverse am i
going to some sort of digital stadium to
interact with other fans of my team and
cheer on in that digital environment
there is really the true potential for
this technology to impact almost every
element of the broader fan experience
[Music]
if nfts are here to stay they could
usher in an entirely new form of fandom
generating value for fans creators and
leagues along the way
but that doesn't necessarily mean
financial returns
whether they're a smart investment for
you right now really comes down to what
you want to get out of them
it's what the value is to you you know
you're the one that's got to spend the
money to own it i think that's where
it's going to get a bit tricky is the
people that have to make a decision on
whether they're buying nfts for the true
love of collecting it if they're buying
it with the idea that they want to make
money on it what's the true
um
fandom for this category is it really is
it primarily full of speculators or is
it primarily full of
people that actually care about the
community that that is created around
the asset that's that's i think the
number one way to tell apart a
sustainable category as opposed to a fad
this is the internet in 1996. that's
where i think we are we're gonna look
back and say there's some great things
that have happened and there's some
things that probably didn't make sense
but
the next
you know amazon google
whoever is probably out there right now
starting to think about what this means
for the next 10 years
[Music]